well now to the battle to become the
next prime minister and the latest poll
of conservative party members has given
liz truss a 34-point lead over her rival
rishi sunak it's the latest one of many
putting the foreign secretary well ahead
of the former chancellor the two are
facing tory party members again tonight
this time in car defender
rishi
is kicking off let's listen to what he's
saying to something as important as our
security
i take a threat-based approach to that
question so what i can commit to is the
following i will invest whatever it
takes to keep all of you and everyone
else in our country safe because that is
the first duty of a prime minister and
it's certainly the first duty of a
conservative prime minister
[Applause]
thank you and then it will be the lady
behind um
hannah i've got actually challenged for
you could you ask this same question of
liz trust please oh okay okay cause i'm
not gonna get the opportunity thank you
uh rishi
it's fantastic husting speech etc but
i've got a simple question for you
forgetting you're an opponent of liz
truss
why would you choose her to be prime
minister and leader of the party
[Laughter]
well i think liz is a good liz is a good
friend of mine we we share the same
values that's why because at the end of
the day we're all conservatives and i
know this whole process is designed to
elicit the differences but we can't
forget the fact that we're on the same
team we're all the same members of the
same family here and
i know what liz knows that the real
opponent is not either of us the real
opponent is kierstarma and i know that
she will also give her all to making
sure that we all work together to beat
kierstama at the next election because
that's the biggest task we all have and
if you think she's the best person to do
that so be it but i think i am but what
i can tell you is she will give her
heart and soul to making sure we do
because she knows who the real opponent
is it's not me it's not anyone else it's
kierstarm in the labour party that's
what we gotta go smash
you